we were just in Europe we were leaving
the UK and we're flying into Amsterdam
my passport beep my wife's
passport
beep Jacob's
passport alarms it turns out to get into
Europe your passport has to
be valid for more than three months more
and so they were like he's not allowed
in and so he was like we're trying
everything they called the US Embassy
the embassy was like yeah we'll let them
into their country country and the other
countries were like that's not how this
[__] works but so he goes all right
one one more thing could you uh could
you just text them and say that he has
uh a a a learning disability and that I
was like just telling me special needs
and we can't split
up and I was like hey dude can you act
[__] for like 4
hours and he was like yep I definitely
can do that
absolutely but that the response made me
laugh the most they're like hey he has
he has special needs like they they need
to be with him like can can he still
travel and they were like well then they
need to go home with him yeah yeah
yeah I was like [__] that's a really
good answer oh you're going to pull the
good parenting [__] on me [__]
you because when I used to go to
Disneyland because we were in uh
California with the kids oh man we'd get
in a long line and one of these three
had to go to the bathroom so we had to
get on line and then we get back in line
and we'd wait in line again and then
somebody had to go to the bathroom and
it used to drive me [__]
crazy so one day I turn to them I go hey
which one of you wants to be
handicapped and they were like what I go
someone's in a wheelchair for the rest
of the day who wants
it and I I was like actually you know
what cuz my daughter's the best actor
out all of them I like you know what
you're in it don't don't overplay it
just enough you can already make
yourself cry God help whoever finds you
and um yeah because it couldn't it
couldn't have been me because I would
have laughed you would have laugh the
whole time and your brother would have
gone too dramatic so she was perfect
right and so um I was like give me a
little limp I was on the way up to the I
go give me a little limp we got to
pretend like this happened in the park
they don't want any problems with
injuries in the
park so just tell them you twisted your
knee or something we're going to get you
in the chair and my daughter was like me
I got it I got it I got it and I said
[__] great so I go hey my daughter
Twisted her knee in the park getting off
of a
ride just we need a chair for the rest
of the day and they were like absolutely
that happened in there I go yeah they're
like you need anything else I'm like no
and they're like yeah just take the
chair so we [__] skipped all the
lines every line the rest and every time
so I had a like a you know one of those
boots that you can buy at CVS I kept one
in the truck of card whenever we went to
Disneyland I was like who wants to be
handicapped today and they were like
yeah it was either a boot or a knee
brace it was one of the two I think at
one point we even bought crutches there
was a full commit to the bit for a good
couple years yeah it was fun it was fun
for a while until they cut on they were
like hey that doesn't work anymore I was
like [__] okay the weirdest thing he's
ever said to you the weirdest thing I've
ever said to him yeah oh I can tell you
exactly what it
was okay he was uh he was high
he and he had taken and he had taken too
much some of you might have seen this
story online he had high he was high he
had taken my
Edibles and I walk you know when
someone's high when you walk into the
room and they're just in only in their
underwear laying on their bed
like and and this is the weirdest thing
he ever said to me he was
twiddling he was doing this on his
chest and uh I go you okay dude and he
goes I think
so I go can I do anything for you and
he's going like this and he
goes can you hear
that I go no and he goes then you can't
do anything for
me yeah but that [__] me up when he
was like can you hear that I'm like that
you're high as [__] I was smoking we
since I was 14 years old yeah
rookie than you this those [__]
chicks when I was four pack of maror
Reds in my
[__] look dude if you grew up in a
certain era when you said that dude was
smoking M red you like he'll [__] your
sister I'd watch out for
him yeah know the one waving p in the P
yes yes
yes can you be more
specific what was it like it was a great
time she was a great
boss um we did some [__] really
ridiculous things to people what I I
will tell you my favorite prank that
ever happened on the show happened to me
I'm a huge uh Foo Fighters and Dave girl
fan so one day Dave girl shows up and he
hands me a signed food fighter
shirt and he was like you wear I go I'm
gonna wear this on the show can I wear
on the show and he was like yeah you can
wear on the show so I put it
on and um
when I get on the show Chelsea goes hey
I got to show you a video and it's a
video of Dave girl on his motorcycle he
pulls into the parking lot and he's been
driving from the valley on this parking
lot in a leather head to toe suit and
the valley is probably 40 minutes away
it's hot in that suit and he steps off
the bike and he takes off his helmet and
his glorious hair shakes all over the
place he unzips this the motorcycle
jacket
he takes the shirt that I'm wearing out
from his taint
area got to tip your
cap and he goes this is for you Josh and
I'm wearing this
shirt on national
TV and Chelsea was like how's it smell
and I was like Smells Like Teen Spirit
yeah do you still have a desk with a
built to laugh does he still have a desk
the desk that I built behind the dick
picture that I saw yeah I'm pretty sure
when we moved out of that house I I
either sold it or destroyed it my wife
and I were out of town so we had him
just sell everything out of the house
right there were just a couple of things
we were like don't sell nope no no I'm
putting nope I'm going to stop right
there do you know where I'm going for
this I no I know you tried to sell the
sauna for
$100 but you would you wouldn't let
somebody buy your old cranky ass
basketball hoop for $100 but you're like
yeah I don't like that SAA you can take
it there were no mom said you guys said
whatever you sell in the house don't you
know saa's worth more than $100 dude I
you said get rid of everything and
anything you sell you get to keep the
money and I was like [__] it that's
another 100 take it I like that's right
I forgot I that was your you gave me no
limitations I sold I sold a set of golf
clubs for 75 bucks you're I know dude
but also don't sound disappointed hold
on I [__] I came home I'm like where
are my cloves and I Beth was like I just
told him to get rid of whatever's in the
garage I'm like and and also don't don't
sound disappointed like you golf yeah I
know it's just nice to have him
yeah